From deep sea sci-fi to a Hitchcock classic, if
you want to see any of these movies or TV shows,
you'd best dig out the DVD player — because
you won't find them online anytime soon.
Despite being one of the most successful
directors in the history of cinema,
some of James Cameron's back catalog remains
unavailable online. Take, for example,
the 1994 Arnold Schwarzenegger film True
Lies, which cannot be rented, purchased,
or streamed legally in the United States…
although it is available on Disney+ in the UK.
Another such film is The Abyss, a 1989 sci-fi
film about a group of scientists who attempt
to recover a sunken nuclear submarine and its
crew. As they explore the depths of the ocean,
the team comes across a non-terrestrial
intelligence surrounding the damaged craft.
The Abyss wasn't exactly a huge success at
the box office, grossing just over $50 million
domestically, but it won plenty of plaudits from
critics and has since become a minor cult classic.
However, while it was previously streaming on
Netflix, The Abyss has not been available to
watch on the internet for an extended period
of time. In fact, the movie hasn't even been
released on Blu-ray — although Cameron himself has
hinted that a 4K remastered release is on the way.
Based on the Thomas M. Disch story of the
same name, The Brave Little Toaster is a
1987 animated film from director Jerry Rees. It
follows an anthropomorphic toaster who comes to
life when humans aren't around, kind of like
a more breakfast-y version of the toys from
Toy Story. Along with a wide array of other
electrical appliances, the toaster sets out
to try and find its owner after they fail to
return to the holiday home for several years.
"Things could be worse, you know."
"How? How could they be worse?"
"They couldn't, I lied."
Despite limited success at the box office,
The Brave Little Toaster was able to find
some popularity on home video and received
largely positive reviews from critics. The
film was broadcast on the Disney Channel
and enjoyed a small theatrical release,
and was later followed by two sequels: The Brave
Little Toaster to the Rescue and The Brave Little
Toaster Goes to Mars, both of which are available
to stream online through Disney+. However,
the original film is absent from any streaming
service and cannot be purchased or rented online.
Although many modern TV fans might not know it,
Murphy Brown was one of the most popular sitcoms
on television through the 1980s and 1990s. It
aired for nearly a decade and broadcast a total
of 260 episodes across that time. Candice Bergen
portrayed Murphy Brown, a recovering alcoholic who
works as an investigative journalist. And if you
need proof that Murphy Brown was a bona fide pop
culture phenomenon, take a look at the countless
awards it won, including numerous Primetime Emmys.
So why is Murphy Brown destined to remain
solely in the world of physical media? Well,
it's complicated. For one thing, the show was
produced by Warner Bros. despite airing on CBS,
so it's not actually clear where it could stream.
It also utilized a large amount of music, meaning
the songs would all need to be licensed all
over again — and the sheer number of Motown hits
featured in the series makes it cost-prohibitive.
Unfortunately, you won't have much luck finding
this show on modern home media, either, as
only the first season was ever released on DVD.
Moonlighting was a comedy-drama series
that starred Bruce Willis as a private
detective and Cybill Shepherd as his business
partner. Airing on ABC between 1985 and 1989,
the series crossed genres,
frequently broke the fourth wall,
and included a number of fantasy elements.
The show was also responsible for bringing
Willis to the public's attention and had a
hit theme song from jazz star Al Jarreau.
Moonlighting garnered a positive reception and won
a number of high-profile awards, including several
Primetime Emmys. However, it has failed to appear
online in any form, with some outlets suggesting
that this may be due to music rights issues. The
series contains a large number of songs in every
episode and licensing all of that music might not
be worth the cost of adding it to Hulu or Disney+.
"Kids today — it's always gimme, gimme, gimme."
Let It Be is a 1970 documentary film that
charts the creation of The Beatles' final
studio album. The film features no narration
or interviews, instead showing the musicians
as they prepare for the upcoming record
by rehearsing songs and discussing the
recording process. Although there are no
obvious fights depicted in the documentary,
the tension between each of the band's members
is palpable; Let It Be provides a fascinating
glimpse into the internal conflicts that would
cause them to split up a month before the movie's
release. The film culminates in a full recording
of the band's iconic final rooftop concert.
While Let It Be has been given a few
limited home media releases in the past,
it has not been reissued or made available
via streaming. Speaking to Rolling Stone,
Paul McCartney refuted rumors that he had blocked
its release, but even today fans still cannot
access the original documentary. However, much of
the footage from the film was later used in Peter
Jackson's documentary series The Beatles:
Get Back, which is available on Disney+.
Kevin Smith's View Askewniverse movies might not
be to everyone's tastes, but films like Clerks and
Chasing Amy have accrued dedicated fan followings
and widespread praise from critics. The 1999 film
Dogma is in the same mold, although it hasn't
enjoyed the same attention as some of Smith's
other releases. Featuring an ensemble cast driven
by a whole heap of star power, the story follows
a group of religious figures attempting
to prevent two fallen angels from defying
God's will by returning to heaven — an act that
would have disastrous consequences for reality.
The main issue blocking Dogma from
streaming online appears to stem
from a disagreement between Smith
and Harvey Weinstein. The director
told Cinema Blend that Weinstein owns the
rights to the film and that the disgraced
producer is blocking a sale that would
give Smith control over its release.
The Fall is a 2006 movie by Indian
director Tarsem Singh. Based on the
Bulgarian film Yo Ho Ho, the story follows
a stuntman who befriends a young girl in the
hospital while recovering from a number of
severe injuries. To help stave off boredom,
he tells his companion fantastical stories
that come to life in the girl's imagination.
Starring Lee Pace as the stuntman Roy Walker,
the film received mixed reviews and didn't fare
particularly well at the box office — although
Roger Ebert gave it four out of four stars and
recommended it as a once-in-a-lifetime experience.
Produced without any major studio involvement, The
Fall has failed to materialize on any streaming
platforms and isn't available to rent or buy,
meaning the only way to see it is by tracking
down one of the limited DVD or Blu-ray releases.
Before he found widespread fame in Brooklyn
Nine-Nine, Andre Braugher was one of the
stars of another police-based television
series: Homicide: Life on the Street.
"Do you know what gravitas
sounds like? Greetings. All."
Based on the David Simon book that would
also inspire The Wire, this NBC series
ran from 1993 until 1999, spanning seven
seasons, 122 episodes, and a TV movie.
The show is highly regarded by many; in 2007,
Time even counted it among the best television
shows ever made. Life on the Street was
also nominated for dozens of awards,
including a number of Primetime Emmy Awards.
Several different DVD releases have been
released over the years, but there is currently
no way to legally access it online. This may
well be another music rights issue, as the
show features a lot of contemporary music,
although the involvement of a number of different
production companies probably didn't help, either.
Directed by Scott Hicks, the 1996
movie Shine is largely based on the
real-life events surrounding pianist
David Helfgott. From a young age,
the future musician is forced to learn to
play at the insistence of his abusive father,
but the pressure of performing eventually leads
him into a mental health crisis. Geoffrey Rush
brought the tortured pianist to life in Shine
and won considerable acclaim for his performance,
while the film in general was almost
universally praised by critics and audiences.
Sadly, Shine is not available for streaming
in any location. The movie was released on DVD
shortly after its theatrical debut, while
a Blu-ray version came out in 2010 — so,
while it's not easy to find and
watch, it's not impossible either.
Green Street Hooligans is a 2005 crime film
that stars Charlie Hunnam and Leo Gregory as
British football hooligans who are joined by an
American visiting his family. The film charts
how the Green Street Elite fights other rival
groups and travels to football matches across
the country. However, events quickly take
a tragic turn as Elijah Wood's character,
Matt, is exposed to the gruesome
consequences of hooligan culture.
Those living outside of the US might have more
luck being able to watch Green Street Hooligans:
It's available to buy and rent on
a variety of services in the UK,
for example, including Microsoft, YouTube, Amazon,
and Apple. This may well be because Green Street
Hooligans, known simply as Green Street in the UK,
simply lacks international appeal, as the subject
matter is very specific to that country. As such,
it has not been picked up by any overseas
streaming services or digital distributors.
Based on the comic series of the same name,
Tales from the Crypt was an HBO anthology
series that ran for seven seasons between
1989 and 1996. It mixed elements of horror,
comedy, and dark fantasy to deliver stories
that often included graphic violence and
mature themes. The series was hosted by a
mysterious figure known as the Cryptkeeper,
who would introduce storylines and talk directly
to the viewer. Over the years, a number of guest
stars featured in Tales from the Crypt, and
the series also received a number of spin-offs.
"What's the matter with you? Want to keep
that 90lb corpse for the rest
of your death? Keep pumping!"
The show's absence from modern streaming
services — including HBO Max — appears to
be due to complicated rights issues. TNT
executive Kevin Reilly even told Deadline
that Tales from the Crypt suffers from the most
complicated rights structure has ever seen in
his career." The fact that the comic book series
has been sold multiple times to different owners
has undoubtedly made it even harder to reboot
or re-release the franchise in recent times.
Created by Jon Beckerman and Rob Burnett
with the help of David Letterman,
Ed is a comedy-drama series that
first hit television screens in
2000. The show follows Tom Cavanagh's
character Ed Stevens, a down-on-his-luck
lawyer who loses his job after making an
expensive mistake. To make matters worse,
he discovers that his wife is having an affair.
Ed immediately decides to go back to his hometown,
where he chases the affections of a local
woman and reunites with his best friend.
Having run for four seasons and received generally
positive reviews, you'd probably expect Ed to be
available on a variety of platforms — but it
isn't. Even the show's creators are unsure
why it hasn't been added to any digital service,
with Burnett suggesting that it might be due to
a combination of music rights and the fact that
NBC-Universal and Paramount co-own the series.
The 1940 Alfred Hitchcock movie Rebecca is a film
adaptation of Daphne du Maurier's 1938 novel of
the same name. Rebecca stars Laurence Olivier as
a widower who falls in love with a young woman,
played by Joan Fontaine. Like many
of Hitchcock's other films, though,
this is not so much a simple romance as
it is a psychological thriller — one that
revolves around a dark secret in the
widower's past. The movie was a huge
success when it was released and won two
Academy Awards, including Best Picture.
Even with its award success and acclaim,
Rebecca cannot be watched in any digital format.
It occasionally airs on Turner Classic Movies,
and the Criterion Collection has released
the film on both DVD and Blu-ray. The fact
that it is not available digitally has never
been explained, and it's all doubly confusing
considering that many other celebrated Alfred
Hitchcock films are readily accessible online.